let's begin here I want to begin with
border fiction this week those
long-weighted House series kicked off
first up the busted Southern border now
for sure I thought Republicans and
Democrats were going to agree at least
acknowledge what we all have been saying
for a long time a border is wide open
because it is almost impossible to
ignore the unprecedented numbers of
Migrant encounters get this for the last
120 days we're averaging 2450 a day
that's over 300 000 known got away since
October that's a separate column drugs
the fentanyl infiltrating our drug
Supply poisoning children faster than
any other age group does that concern
you I would think the amount seized in
the first three months of fiscal year
2023 is more than with seasonal of 2019
and 2020 combined 9 351 pounds enough to
kill every American yeah that's you and
the Border crosses evading our own
border agents up 40 and just in the Del
Rio sector Alone 4 million
probably over that crossed illegally
since Biden entered the White House so
it made total sense to me that
Republicans would choose the border to
be the first area of oversight to have
hearings because with these hard facts
of course both sides would have to agree
that there was a problem and the only
point of contention would be how to
solve the problem we can agree on that
right
no
and now this the first hearing will
showcase the racist Tendencies of the
extreme Republican wing of the party
that seeks to close the border to
refugees from places like Cuba and
Venezuela it almost makes me miss their
usual obsession with conspiracy theories
and the FBI many republicans in Congress
seem a tent on demonizing migrant
families and Asylum Seekers portraying
them as Fentanyl traffickers and violent
criminals we keep hearing from our
Republican colleagues that the border is
open and that the Biden caused this
crisis could you comment on this well we
we don't see that is it your experience
that an increase in migrants is tied to
an increase in uh fentanyl we haven't
seen that because first of all they come
with very little things I mean they get
a backpack they get you know think
they're carrying things that are very
easy they're vetted very properly
that judge should be embarrassed what an
embarrassment he is so if you want to
close the border you are a racist okay
you got it and the only have backpacks
that nothing illegal could have actually
fit in a backpack right just your
clothes wrong look at this picture that
bill malusion took two pounds of
fentanyl pills 172 pounds of marijuana
all fit in a backpack I guess what we
are seeing here right before our eyes
must be all a lie one big optical
illusion that's what Corey Bush thinks
anyway
Republicans want us to so they can hold
these hearings to mass the fact that
they have no affirmative agenda that
actually helps people so they can spew
their lies about immigrants bringing
fentanyl across the border
she's a treat No Agenda even Jerry
Nadler had to admit the Republicans do
in fact have an agenda whether he agrees
with it or not is something different
extreme Republican majority fails to
offer genuine Solutions and resorts to
political theater Republicans have
proposed building a wall shutting down
the Asylum system and defunding the
Department of Homeland Security
those are not serious proposals really
what's not serious about him actually
they are serious proposals and they
worked for those who think this border
problem is not a national problem maybe
you haven't left your house since
President Biden took office because
cities around the country are being
overrun by illegals he got millions of
migrants so pouring into our major
cities getting free housing free
Transportation uh flat screen TVs three
meals a day they get a menu ping pong
tables costing cities like the one I'm
in right now millions of dollars and by
the way we're over budget but somehow a
majority of the left still do not think
this is a problem still do not think
they should be handled and still do not
think this is a crisis that needs to be
confronted immediately the real problem
with all this if we can't agree on what
the problem actually is we'll never get
a solution and that's what's so
disturbing especially with the Biden
Administration hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
says you will not get it anywhere else